es momento de pasar a hablar de las
noticias de salud con mi compañera Amara
Romero sala Maru Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela vamos a comenzar
hablando de un nuevo estudio que nos
arroja luz sobre la protección contra el
Coby 19 que nos da habernos contagiado
Sí es lo que se llama inmunidad natural
no dada por el contagio como decías
previo de virus que provoca el covid-19
es un meta de estudio es decir que
recoge datos de muchos otros estudios y
hace un análisis de todo lo que sabemos
hasta ahora en total 65 estudios hechos
en 19 países y es bastante esclarecedor
hace la diferencia entre omicron y las
variantes previas de omicron y vemos que
por ejemplo contra un nuevo contagio
contra una reinfección haberse
contagiado antes proteja un 36% contra
ómicron pero un 78% contra las variantes
previas contra la enfermedad sintomática
es decir contra además de estar
contagiado enfermarse también vemos unos
porcentajes parecidos mucho más Bajos en
omicron mucho más altos contra las otras
variantes y quizás uno de los datos más
importantes es que contra la enfermedad
grave Es decir contra la hospitalización
o contra la muerte por covid-19 en ambos
casos en todas las variantes se llega
alrededor del 90 por ciento sabíamos que
protegen no sabíamos que habernos
contagiado de Kobe 19 protege pero tener
estudios de esta magnitud pues hace
tener los datos mucho más claros y
también poder empezar a tomar decisiones
al respecto de esto vemos además que
también eran cifras que no eran muy
distintas a las cifras que ofrece la
protección por vacunación es importante
decir por cierto que estos datos eran a
40 semanas de haberse contagiado por
covid-19 es decir unos 9-10 meses
después de haberse contagiado Pero sin
embargo en este punto importante también
recordar porque durante mucho tiempo
pues había personas que para evitar
vacunarse decían que se querían
contagiar de Kobe 19 para tener esta
protección es muy distinto los riesgos
de enfermedad por Kobe 19 que los
riesgos de una vacunación que sabemos
que al final eran unos leves efectos
secundarios Claro pero estaban estas
personas que definitivamente no apoyan
de las vacunas y le digo francamente es
tranquilizante después de esos días tan
oscuros que pasamos Sí por supuesto
ahora Qué implicaciones Podría tener
esto en las políticas públicas alrededor
de la vacunación pues estos autores del
estudio que es de la Universidad de
Washington Por cierto Proponen una serie
de cosas que tienen que ver como con
adaptar las políticas públicas de todas
estas políticas de vacunación contra el
19 que se llevan implementando Desde
hace dos años por ejemplo una de las
primeras cosas que recuerdan que debemos
monitorear las tasas de infección
existentes y de infecciones previas
también según variante porque nos pueden
dar muchas luces sobre cómo puede ser
una siguiente ola o un siguiente brote
no saber cuántas personas se contagiaron
nos puede dar información para saber
cuántas personas en este momento están
protegidas actualmente por ese contagio
también Proponen que se tenga en cuenta
Esta inmunidad por contagio en todos lo
que tenga que ver con pases vacunales
con restricciones de movimientos o de
viajes no a incluirlo como un factor que
demostraría que una persona puede estar
más protegida contra el covid 19 de lo
que ya esta una persona que no se ha
enfermado recientemente o que no se ha
vacunado y que también se incluyen las
guías de vacunación es decir si pasaste
el Coby 19 hace poco tomarlo en cuenta
como si fuera una dosis de refuerzo algo
parecido para luego tener la vacunación
más tarde y optimizar un poco así la
distribución ante las vacunas no también
por supuesto estudiar más porque
actualmente la variante más prevalentes
ve a cinco ve a cuatro ve a cinco que
son las variantes de omicron que no se
incluyen en estos estudios por lo tanto
Bueno pues tener más investigación para
tenerlo más adaptado también al día a
día actual de hoy en día que será que en
la última década del discurso alrededor
de los carbohidratos están preponderante
vamos a hablar de otro tema y de otra
investigación que vincula a estos
carbohidratos con las enfermedades del
corazón si también es un estudio muy
esclerecedor vamos primero a repasar los
datos Y luego a ver Qué implicaciones
también puede tener esta publicado en
BMX y medicine y la principal conclusión
es que comer más carbohidratos no está
asociado a tener más riesgos de
enfermedad cardiovascular excepto en un
caso que es el caso de los azúcares
libres que son todos los azúcares
añadidos por ejemplo no Además de los
que se encuentran de forma natural en la
miel o en los zumos en los jugos de
fruta en este caso si hay un vínculo
entre consumir en exceso esto y riesgo
de enfermedad cardiovascular las cifras
que nos dieron es que aumenta este
riesgo en un 7% en todas las
enfermedades cardiovasculares en general
un 6% en la cardiopatía isquémica que es
cuando se obstruyen los vasos sanguíneos
y un 10% en el ictus es decir como el
infarto cerebral cerebral en este caso
si hay un riesgo entre este tipo de
carbohidratos y un mayor riesgo de
enfermedades del corazón bien y fuera de
todas las creencias Cuáles son las
recomendaciones entonces según esta
investigación del consumo de
carbohidratos claro como tú decías eso
hace un alimento bastante demonizado muy
debatido no Y esto es un buen estudio
para recordar que quizás no tiene tanto
que ver con la cantidad de carbohidratos
que se consume sino con la calidad de
Estos tipos de alimentos recordemos que
son los azúcares pero también son el
almidón también están las fibras estamos
hablando de granos
basta también le también se encuentran
las legumbres frutas o productos
lácticos y es importante recordar que
cuando lo ingerimos estos carbohidratos
los descomponemos en glucosa Y eso es lo
que da energía a nuestras células a
nuestros órganos para funcionar es decir
que es un grupo de alimentos muy amplio
y muy importante para nuestro día a día
no de los más importantes que tenemos
que consumir pero como decíamos tener en
cuenta la calidad uno de los datos del
estudio por ejemplo era que en cambio Si
se aumentaba en 5 gramos diarios la
ingesta de fibra que es uno de los tipos
de carbohidratos se reducía en cambio
nuestro riesgo de enfermedades
cardiovasculares también hablaban de
sustituir por ejemplo los cereales
refinados por ejemplo unos cereales de
caja con azúcares añadidos etcétera por
cereales integrados no podría ser
integrales Perdón podría ser por ejemplo
consumir avena en vez de todo eso
refinado o procesado en ese caso
sustituir algo de mala calidad por buena
calidad nos podría ayudar mucho a
reducir nuestro riesgo de enfermedad
equilibrio que tanto nos cuesta por
supuesto Ángela gracias a usted muchas
gracias